- Laurette Hinse est une force
de la nature. Énergique, elle at
103 ans.
LAURETTE HINSE, 102 ans
- Je m'efforce de vivre le mieux
d'ouvrage aux autres, là!
Je suis chanceuse
parce que je suis autonome.
- Bonjour, Madame Hinse.
Comment ça va?
- Elle habite aujourd'hui en
résidence, mais a eu sa maison
jusqu'à 96 ans et sa voiture
Pour pouvoir cont
à marcher, elle s'est fait
remplacer une hancà l'âge de 10.
- Je vais au centre-ville, là,
sur la rue Notre-Dame,armacie, ,
à la bibliothèque.
- On l'écoute parler du dernier
- J'ai commencé à enseigner
en 36 à 150 $ par année. C'est
comique, hein. C'était Duplessis
qui était premier ministre,
puis on voulait tous l'étouffer.
Je suis un peu féministe,je le !
- Le nombre de centenaires en 5 ans au pays,
selon le dernier recensement,
il y avait 1975 centenaires
joyeux anniversaire.
- Merci.
- Le 6 mai, Hélène Girard
en compagnie de ses filles.Sa gt
plus, augmente aussi en flèche :
En 2021, ils étaient 25 615
au Québec et 110 705 au Canada.
HÉLÈNE GIRARD, 98 ans
- Je le crois pas. Je pensais
jamais de me rendre là. Jamais.
bien se nourrir, bien faire
attention à nous autres.
DAVID LUSSIER, gériatre
- Les gens qui viventux, ils sot
particuliers par rapport
aux autres. Souvent, ils ont eu
de meilleures habitudes de vctis
physiquement. Mais les grosses
différences, c'est dans la santé
psychologique : c'est des gens
c'est des gens aussi
plus déterminés.
- David Lussier dirige une
aide de plus en plus de patient.
- On a été très le cancer, pourr
les maladies cardiaques, pou
traiter les maladies cérébro-
vasculaires, donc moins vite, ms
on n'a pas réussi encore à
traiter, et ça, c'est ce que
je fais, là, à bien traiter
- Est aussi arrivée la COVID.
morts, des milliers d'autres
ont soufontraintesontraintesonts
sanitaires. Laurette Hinse
a dû t
de confinement dans son petit
logement- Je me posais la quest:
bien, co
qu'au Québec, à Victoriaville,
il faut
Bien, j'aimerais autant mourir.
- On pouvait faireconditionneme,
de la ma
tous les jours, mais grâce
au COVID
on est restreints.
- C'est assez trisà quel point t
détériorés. Oui, ige,ge,ge,ge,g,
mais aussi, il y a aussi que ça
a été amplifié paret par le mann
et d'actié
leur solitude. Quand on a
100 ans, les deuils
s'accumulent.
- On a trois personnes de notre
écédées en
deux mois. Plus jeunes que moi!
partir. Tu sais, c'est videère .
- Ça fait 25 ans que je suis
avec mon mari. Mais je
m'encourage tout le temps,
mieux, tout le temps.
temps.
- Je sais que nos personnes, one
côté, alors on bâtit des centres
Quand je la vois vieillir, je
réalise qu'un simple téléphone,
ça fait sa journée, ça lui donne
de l'énergie.
- Hélène Girard et Laurette
trois générations de descendants
qui leur donnent des nouvelles
et qui les aident à cheminer
- Moi, je suis pas prête à dire
que les aînés sont oubliés.
- Mais même à 100 ans,
de la santé n'est pas toujours
facile.
- Si j'ai besoin de téléphoner
qui nous répond. Le robot dit
toujours : "Je n'ai pas compris
votre nom." Ça, le robot dit ça.
Ça peut prendre six mois avanttt
pas un service pour les aînés.se
décision, Monsieur le présid
parce que...
- Ex-ministre de la SantéHébertt
aujourd'hui partie du Consei
national des aînés, un organisme
fédéral dont la mission
pour améliorer leur quotidien.
Tous ne vieillissent pas aussi
bien que Laurette et Hélène.
École de santé publique
ne
dix ans, l'une des nations
les plus vieilles ellement,
c'est qu'au Québec, au Canada,
les soins à domicile sont
anémiques. Il y en pratiquement
avec les pays européensays asia.
Les soins à domicile sont
IRARD, fille d'Hélène
- On s'aperçoit co
aidant la difficulté,
les restrictions des soins
la première ligne, OK,dans les ,
c'est nous, les suivants.
améliore au Québec pour pas
nous éch
- Ça, c'est ma compagne
qui vient m'aider.
- Contente d'avoir
de sa vie, Hélène nous a même
fait une petite danse
- Une petite danse!
- Ce matin, ça va très bien.
nous a connous a connous a conné
son secret pour être encore
heureuse à 102 as choses
qui nous font plaisir.
Si tu attends après les autres,
là, tu peux attendre longtemps.
r,
Radio-Canada, Victoriaville.